I had someone reach out through referral and they recommended a city for me.
I got them three leads in four days. They charge high prices and are proud of it.
I got on a call with them both to close and they liked everything until it came to talking about
price. One business owner said 1500 per month is fair but they have to think about it for two weeks.
I wasn't able to use the method where I said I have someone on the hook. I tried to tell them
I'll need to look for another business owner while they consider and they said that's fine.
What could I have done differently there to have gotten them to make the decision on the phone?
So basically, long story short, he wasn't able to close the deal on the spot.
The one business owner said that the 1500 was fine but they need two weeks to think about it.
Just a reminder, whenever you guys are getting objections, this is going back to sales 101,
whether you're selling freaking ridiculously priced bottled water, shout out to Park Plaza
for using glass when they don't need to, that's fine. High priced bottled water, t-shirts,
freaking power banks, it doesn't matter what you're selling. If you are getting an objection
from your customer, it's almost 100% of the time not what you did. It's not where the objection
came that you went wrong. It's the step or a step before. Now, without getting all the context and
without being there as a fly on the wall, without watching over your shoulder, without knowing
exactly what was said and the timeline and all the rest, what I can tell you is that I believe,
based on what you're telling me, that what happened is the setup, which is right before
the close. The setup is where it went wrong. What I mean by that is that the business owner clearly
felt like they could come to you and say they needed time to think about it. We don't get that.
I don't get that. Our agency doesn't get that. We just don't. The reason why is because I know
it's coming. Every person on this earth, every human on this earth is going to say they need
to think about it because no one wants to make the wrong decision. I already know that's coming.
As part of the training, what we talked about is the setup. As part of the setup, we want to
eliminate objections. We don't want to wait for them. This is a prime example. When you
wait for an objection to come, now you have to overcome it. When you attack the objection first,
when you eliminate the objection first, it's so much easier. It takes one sentence. It takes one
quick conversation. It takes one example, and it's not an issue. If you wait for the objection to
come, it is almost impossible or extremely difficult to overcome. It is extremely hard
to tell someone they can't think about it versus telling someone, hey, all I ask is that by the end
of this call, you give me a yes or no. If it's a maybe, it's a no. That is so much easier to do.
Than to wait until they object. I can tell you based on what you're telling me that you went
wrong in the setup. You went wrong in not setting the expectations, not being clear that I need an
answer on this. You don't need to say it like that. Hey, I need you to give me a yes or no. We don't
want to spook them. Sometimes I'll say that if the business owner and me were vibing and whatever,
you went wrong in the setup. That needs to be addressed. You need to either say that on the
phone. What I like to bring, I like to definitely bring it up in the screencast, but I also like to
bring it up on the phone call. I'm talking to these business owners. If I'm the one that's still
closing deals, which I've removed myself from that aspect, thank goodness, I did that for years.
I say thank goodness not because I don't like it. I love it. I say thank goodness because it's
allowed me to scale now because I don't have to be there and get deals. You went wrong in the setup.
You needed to bring that up in the screencast that you were going to need a decision because
you need to find someone as soon as possible. These leads are valuable. It's money going down
the drain. I'm going to give you some for free, but you need to let me know by the end of this.
That's all I ask. Don't leave me in the whole no man's land or are you going to think about it,
that kind of thing. That's all I ask from you, Mr. Business Owner. By the way, make sure that you
have decision makers on the phone. There's no pressure. I've given you the leads. I'm going
to show you the pricing. I'm going to go over everything. You're going to have every bit of
information. That's it. You went wrong in the setup. Now, one more thing. If you do get that
objection, I want to cover this really quick. Let's say you to get the objection of, I want
to think about it. I need to think about it, whatever. Now, your only option is to try and
overcome the objection. Again, just remember, and I think we even have this in fact almost,
and I know we do, inside of the premium sales training library, which if you don't have access
to it, that is the library that's for those students that are paid in full. There were some
of you guys that before we started doing the funding and everything else, we're on payment
plans when we used to do those internally. If you are not already, make sure you get yourself paid
in full so you can have access to the premium sales training library. If you are paid in full,
message Fix It Felix to get access to all that material. But in there, we have a training on
Feel Felt Found. We want to make sure, just a quick recap, make sure that you let the business
owner know that you feel them. Hey, I feel you. I understand. You don't want to make a wrong
decision, whatever, right? Felt, you want to make sure that you let them know that another business
owner felt the exact same way. You can say, I felt the same way when doing such and such a thing,
but it's more powerful if you say, you know, remember that guy Joe I told you about that
we work with in Cincinnati? Yeah, it's funny you say that. He felt the exact same way. He's like,
dude, I got to think about it. Feel, then felt, and then it comes to found. But what Joe found is
that at the end of the day, he would rather, even though he wasn't 100% certain, he's like,
I can't be 100% certain about anything. He would rather take that slight risk than me go with
somebody else and work with somebody else because I've given him the free leads. He's already looking
to do something different from what he's already doing. He needed to grow and it just made sense.
So that's the feel felt found. And then you go in for the close again. Okay.
The only other thing I would mention before you do that, I skipped a step, make sure that you
make sure that that is their actual objection. Okay, you need to tie them down. Okay, Bob,
I get it. So you want to think about it, right? So besides thinking about it,
and I'm doing air quotes, because that's a broad thing. Besides you thinking about it.
Is there any other thing, any other question, any other reason that this wouldn't make sense
today? No. Okay. Now I'm going to go a little deeper. Let me ask you this, Bob. And again,
I'm not going to be pushy. I just want to understand what exactly do you need to think about?
Because I know that you know where your budget's at, right? You run the business,
you know where the budget's at. I know that your partners are on the phone. What exactly
when you say you want to think about what exactly do you mean? And they're going to tell you,
right? And you're going to dig and you're going to dig and you're going to make sure and you're
going to isolate that one specific issue and make sure that's the actual cause. Then you're
going to use the feel felt found method. And then you're going to go back in for the close. Okay.
Tie down the objection, feel felt found, go back for the close. And you don't need to be super
aggressive. You could do it in your own way. You don't need to just be super blunt. I like to be
that way sometimes. Sometimes I don't. It just depends on the situation, but you can do it the
way that you want to do it. But again, think about it. The setup, you could have easily just
told them that on the call, right? On the screencast. That would have just been simple.
A line, a sentence, two sentences versus you didn't and now you're at objection
overcoming and now you have to tie it down and now you have to do the feel felt found.
And now you have to go back in for the close and it's a little bit uncomfortable and you're
going to sweat a little bit and you're going to, it's so much easier to eliminate than it
is to overcome. Sorry, that was a long answer, but that's the truth. Okay.